en el discurso lo que realmente me llamó
la atención fue que dijo hasta la muerte
estaremos proclamados en el servicio del
Estado Entonces eso nos envía ya el
mensaje de Que obviamente frente a los
próximos cinco años va a seguir ahí en
el poder que van a haber cambios y sobre
todo es muy interesante Cómo se presenta
como el padre de la nación muy familiar
diciendo hijos nietos mujeres y sobre
todo enviando un mensaje de igual manera
como a las minorías hacia los Derechos
Humanos hablo de las mujeres exactamente
en varios momentos sobre todo cuando
dijo la violencia contra la mujer está
penalizada en Turquía ese es un mensaje
claro y otro mensaje que también
contradictorio con La retirada del
convenio no que precisamente lucha
contra la violencia de género totalmente
y otro momento que llama también
bastante la atención es como leyendo uno
entre líneas cuando él manifiesta somos
un país somos una nación nadie es decir
como un factor externo no va a tener
cabida acá y no nos van a destruir ahí
es un mensaje clarísimo para occidente y
sobre todo para Estados Unidos y para la
Unión Europea que buscaban y esperaban
otros resultados